je suis frappé par l'idée de la fessée
c'est à dire de la localisation de la
tape sur les fesses ce sont arrivés en
france il m'avait nommée vous ça vous
paraît normal de taper les enfants sur
les fesses il ya même un mot pour ça que
j'appelle la fessée mais moi je peux
vous dire que de là où je veux mais j'ai
habité au chili au canada
léo voilà tu mets une tape sur la tête
tu tire l'oreille mais l'idée de quotas
musique
bref non mais qu'est ce que tu veux que
je te dise on est tous d'accord c'est
très consensuel c'est mal de taper les
enfants que veux tu bon je craque comme
j'ai pas parlé des footballeurs on l'a
fait c'est effectivement et mais vous
savez que l'émission de 20 tellement
bizarre je sais pas ce qui sera votée
mais en fait il ya beaucoup de gens qui
pensent
contrairement à nous et notamment
beaucoup de gens de droite qui étaient
contre l'interdiction de la fessée à
l'assemblée nationale c'est une loi a
été votée en juillet dernier interdisant
cette prod pas là et je vois j'ai
toujours été choqué parce que c'est vrai
que la fessée c'est déjà un acte
d'humiliation très clairement et un acte
de violence et si on tolère cette
première violence ça veut dire que on
tolère toutes les violences et je pense
que c'est très important mais dans
l'esprit des de nombreux français et tu
trouves ça normal qu'on puisse comme ça
lever la main sur son enfant pour le
mettre fin à un acte mais je pense que
ça a été une très bonne chose qui a été
faite cette interdiction de la fessée et
j'espère que et d'ailleurs les enfants
en en pris en ont pris conscience parce
qu'il ya énormément d'enfants qui disent
à leurs parents attention ne me touche
pas c'est interdit par la loi
et ben non mais c'est vrai mais c'est
vrai et tant mieux on n'a pas les mêmes
est ce qu'un enfant sa cible enfants de
22 ans
non mais je vous assure non mais je vous
assure que je parle à mes parents qui me
rend compte que leur enfant alors dit ne
me touche pas c'est interdit par la loi
non mais c'est pas dingue ce que je dis
donc ça veut dire quoi que les enfants
ont pris conscience qu'on n'avait pas le
droit de les violenter et ben ça ça
compte parce qu'un enfant qui sera
violente et mais c'est pas drôle et il
ya des enfants qui ont presque tous les
jours enfin il faut arrêter c'est
sûr mais c'est un sujet très grave et
véhicules non mais il ya quand même un
argument qui est fort contre la fessée
c'est que quand on voit quelqu'un donner
une fessée publiquement à lagos
on est choqué et on a envie d'aller à y
revenir et j'ai souvent il ya des
échauffourées entre les landes
d'instruction ont dit vraiment et il ya
quelque chose qui va pas en plus c'est
quand même la preuve que vous n'arrivez
pas à exercer votre autorité sur votre
enfant autrement qu en le frappant enfin
c'est vraiment une preuve de l'échec
pour un père ou une mère que je trouve
catastrophique quoi jimmy alors c'est un
débat particulier parce que jamais on se
posera la question de faute il frapper
ou pas son chien ou son chat
on se pose la question de frapper ou pas
ses enfants même façon qu'on se poserait
pas la question de frappe et son
conjoint sont employés le patron mais là
pour les enfants on se pose une question
et je peux comprendre certains parents
qui parfois sont dépassés face à un
enfant qui n'arrive pas à gérer et dont
la seule réponse serait de mettre une
fessée ce qu'il faut leur expliquer
c'est que le cerveau d'un enfant n'est
pas le même que celui d'un adulte
jusqu'à cinq ans le cerveau est immature
et l'enfant à une dans une tempête
émotionnelle qui fait qu'il va sur
réagir et à cette surréaction si on
répond par la violence on va entraîner
une libération de cortisol c'est un peu
chiant ce que je dis mais c'est très
important
le cortisol entraîne un retard de
maturation cérébrale et entraîne c'est
l'hormone du stress est sécrétée par une
norme à une glande dans le cerveau qui
s'appelle l'amygdale une laisse et
amygdales elle est mature
dès la naissance qui veut donc dire que
l'enfant qui vient de naître à une
amygdale cérébrale qui peut produire du
cortisol en réponse à un stress si vous
violente et un enfant il va être stressé
et le tout des études neurobiologiques
le prouve que vous allez atrophiée son
cortex cérébral qui est le maître
le centre de décision et de l'empathie
violenté un enfant ça pourra donner un
enfant violent via les neurones miroirs
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne dit qu'un
enfant est par exemple reproduit les
comportements des stars mais pourquoi
est ce qu'un enfant dit bah tiens je
vais jouer à moi une fille à la poupée
c'est la maman qui va qui va qui va
faire la cuisine
le papa qui à faire le garagiste parce
qu'ils identifient nos comportements
intensive ou violenté un enfant toute
agression d'armes a même choisi qui va
entraîner ça et puis parallèlement on a
deux enfants qui meurent sur les
couleurs parents de maltraitance tous
les jours et je pense que c'est quelque
chose d'important dans la société de
dire qu'on ne sera pas un enfant ce
n'est pas une méthode éducative
il faut peut-être les accompagner pour
leur faire comprendre pourquoi est ce
que l'enfant est dans cette cola extrême
plutôt bien infliger une punition
qu'elle soit verbale ou physique
caitlin
je trouve évidemment je suis contre et
je trouve qu'il ya de plus en plus
d'études maintenant on sous estime la
science qui sur ce qui devait parler
non mais parce que ça c'est à dire
comment l'enfant et comment il réagit
comment éduquer un enfant comment
éduquer à la discipline positive pour
élever un enfant
comment exercer son autorité sans
frapper sans remettre en question soit
pourquoi est-ce que je discutais avec
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui me dit à cinq
ans regardez ce qu'il a fait il a cassé
ma télé son fils et j'ai dit mais messi
la casse est ouvert pendant l'émission
de cyril hanouna a surtout pas il
adorait cyril hanouna l'enfant de 5 ans
de travaux c'est beau brun avocat rideau
non mais et je lui disais à ce père j'ai
dit mais comment ça s'est passé dans
quelles conditions
mais c'est vrai t'as envie de savoir
effectivement comment l'enfant est élevé
est-ce qu'on écoutait ce qu'ils écoutent
et qu est-ce qu as tu changé ma fille
est ce que les parents se sont séparés
et il faut une remise en question des
parents au lieu de transférer sa colère
son énervement son stress sur son enfant
et c'est ça la réalité aujourd'hui il
faut éduquer les parents à éduquer nos
enfants vers la baie comeau si d'abord
merci jimmy parce que je rentrais - caen
ce soir là mais c'est vrai et kimi est
intéressante explications qui ont été de
dire la jv cortisol et je serai prêt
parce que j'en ai tous un peu fatigués
donc mis sur contre et je rassure ici
des thèmes qui parlent des enfants on ne
peut pas supprimer toutes les festivals
et les coquins et voilà leur ensemble
oui je me demande si bernard laporte
n'est pas plus pas votre maître tout bas
bien déconné c'est tout
karim fait entre les deux toi tu es
d'oldarra qu'elle chérit j'ai pas voulu
être hypocrite sur le sujet est allé
dans le sens du vin parce qu en fait je
fais la distinction c'est moi je suis
vieille france et c'est pas les bobos
contre à masquer le disais c'est tout le
contraire
vieille france peut-être qu'on fait la
distinction entre une maltraitance les
violences aux enfants évidemment qu'on
est contre personne m pour mature et
puis amont et que peu fait partie d'une
certaine génération et c'est vrai que on
n'avait pas de temps d'étude on n'avait
pas tant de grès de 2 c'est vrai qu'on
en a 53 ans j'ai pris quelques fessées
dans ma vie ça m'a pas fait de moi un
père violent ça m'a pas perturbé
ça m'a peut-être remis dans le droit
chemin ma mère est éteint devrait
méditerranéenne et en plus je préfère
très franchement de petites tapes sur
les fesses une fois par an que des
baffes dans la gueule de qui sont une
humiliation totale que qu'on peut voir
est effectivement contre lesquels il
faut lutter donc après moi j'ai pas mis
les pulpes avisé le les parents qui qui
à un moment donné excédés des gens qui
abusent vont lui faire trois petites
fées j'appelle pas ça de la maltraitance
matin la femme a cassé le rétroviseur de
la voiture
elle m'a appelé m'a dit j'ai pété le
rétro en sortant je c pas grave un
enfant qui casserait quelque chose
parfois on a envie de le taper mais
c'est disproportionné non mais c'est des
choses qui arrivent et d'autres se dire
oui mais voilà la petite info il paraît
que sur le pare brise et l'impact d'une
baisse de 2 ou à je termine un divin qui
dit pas
opérationnel mais est-ce qu'on se mieux
aujourd'hui avec l'éducation que l'on
donne de l'enfant roi qui auraient droit
à tous et qui presque commandes auraient
à la maison est ce que c'est mieux
donc les versions merci messieurs voilà
et on retiendra de ce débat que la femme
de 10 me mohamed a cassé le rétroviseur
alors pour à soissons à ben ouais les
gars mais vous aimez c'est la raison
pour laquelle je le disais ouais mais
oui oui vous vous dites toujours les
choses encore mais c'est la vérité je
non mais je les dis que les français
étaient plutôt pour bloquer voilà ils
vont prendre vos opinions et veut dire
qu'elle est en vacances et les pignons
caisse et des enfants vulnérables que
les gens n'ont pas encore pris la peine
d'aller traquer la regarder elle est à
72 % des français sont pour la fessée